So, the next thing we'll look at as
far as the constructing the diagram is
the operations.
In the analysis model, operations
comprise those actions that the users
can undertake to interact
with the text browser.
The call that we're concerned
here with an analysis model and
not a design, okay?
So, we are not trying to fill in
the implementation methods
that are involved.
But rather,
we're using the class model diagram to
describe at a high level
what the user can do.
You can use the identified use
cases to answer the questions,
what internally visible operations
does the text browser respond to?
And, you recall what those were?
>> So
the first was just viewing the text.
That doesn't seem to really elicit
any kind of behavior though.
>> So you're right, there's no event
that the application has to respond to,
to do that.
Assuming that we started it up okay.
>> Okay, and then moving the handle.
>> Okay, so that's certainly going
to be an operation the system
has to respond to.
>> And lastly, re-sizing the view port.
>> And, we could also specify parameters
for those particular operations like,
what's the size of the view port
that the user would like to see?
Or, what's the position of
the handle in the tray,
when the user is using the scroll bar?